I think it's pretty obvious I mean there
was no hedge fund that was levered 40
times there's no hedge fund there was
levered 20 times so there was always
this focus because people i think focus
on the individual investor and that
people were worried about fraud within a
hedge fund it's amazing when you look at
it if you really look at sort of OE even
07 if you look at the amount of money
that was lost in hedge funds just from
fraud right or funds blowing up and
closing down it was pretty de minimis
and when you look at what happened I
think with financial institutions you
know the dollars that people talk about
is sort of trillions of dollars so I and
the reason for that is because of the
leverage it's not because of the equity
that was involved so I think on I think
there was just a real lack of
understanding and it was easier to sort
of pick on hedge funds because people
believe that banks were safe and I think
what was clear and what's been shown is
you know that is really the banks that
needed the oversight not the hedge funds
yeah I mean I think there is I think
part of the reason is there's a big
focus on that people want to sort of
monetize the value that they have in a
company and by doing that you go public
I think being private there's a huge
amount of benefits and being private but
ultimately the reason people go public
is to monetize and to capture that value
like I think it's I you can't blame the
people for doing that I mean I think
what ends up happening is they're taking
a private and they think when somebody
takes a couple private they believe
they're doing it at a very good price
the reason they're going to take it
public is they think they're going to
get a much higher valuation so I think
the vast majority of people in that same
situation would probably do the same
thing does that mean it's right you know
that that's a different issue but
there's there's a huge amount of focus
on sort of what people make and as you
look at that I think that's why people
end up taking companies public
look I think I think what
was very simply said we're putting our
money in we're going to be senior we're
going to get paid X and we can we can
end up doing anything we want until you
take us out I mean I I don't blame the
government for sort of imposing things I
just think they've gone a little bit too
far because what they're doing now is
dealing more with popular sentiment as
opposed to sort of business reasons and
that's that's the real issue it's not
it's that the government has its own
pressures it's hard for her if you're
voting for your congressman and you're
saying well you voted on and that
congressman votes on the bailout to say
that congressman but why is that person
making a million dollars a year I don't
think that's right I'm out of a job and
if I bailed him out I want to limit what
he can make oh I I get it but what they
should have done would say we're putting
in money we're going to be an investor
and we're going to get paid if we don't
get paid then ultimately we're going to
end up owning this company